previously on the walking dead get the
gates open
we've got wounded I want to know why you
stopped bringing more mouths to feed was
a good idea
you're a convicted killer Carly Gemma's
people need to know because we're
hanging by a thread here and I can't see
Lily talked about you without thinking
it's the next thing she's going to say
there's a traitor somebody one of us out
there he or she or they have been taking
things so what's there to go on I found
this
tossed into the garbage hmm you'd only
try to get rid of a flashlight if you're
using it when you shouldn't yeah dad
it's probably duck Jesus now I can stay
out of my way
your other grace detective and I can be
Dick Grayson you're a dick all right
how's it goin wrist hey Ben I bet it was
Ben I totally forgot about him i Ben
what's up - broker welcome was with you
yeah with you oh man you're not in
trouble if it was I know you get nervous
and maybe you went out to go to the
bathroom broke it got word and tossed it
what's with the third degree I didn't
break any flesh hey don't make me kill
you Ben
look at this room if I give you this
looked it means I don't trust you Ben I
don't [ __ ] trust you I need to go to
the ice machine I thought it was over
here but it teleports me oh here it is
all right let's inspect our Sherlock
pills investigates perfect match huh
an ex probably means it was duck we need
to grab him and kill him
dark a clue duck don't make me kick your
face in do you think it is I don't think
it's anything maybe it's a sign
maybe I should punch you in the face it
could be it's pink chalk which is weird
okay back to investigating what the hell
is this [ __ ] are you serious right now I
guess I gotta talk cry me about this
climate would never steal food I can
it's Carly catcha or Ben alright
clammy what's up hey Clementine hailey
do you have any pink chalk no it's gone
somewhere someone's stolen no that's
okay you're so nice Lee what's up not
come on what do you want i demon spawn
what is it I found this piece of pink
chalk and a scuff of it over by the gate
really totally I was calling the scene
for clues yeah duck I got it good job
goddamnit action alright what do you
want what do you want a high five he
wants a high five you [ __ ] kidding me
get out of my face
a flashlight
oh he's going on here
somebody was over here to see I did good
huh
it's shut up doc I mean did fine I
suppose I should go out there and look
around you stay here this time seriously
sir yeah I will hi-fi your face next
time if you go anyway alrighty then
now where do we go huh I guess this way
those bandits gave us hell but they've
been quiet for days now
yeah that sounds pretty terrible Dave
not that long well what do we got here
we're here why would someone leave a dog
[ __ ] bag here it's a bag of something
bag of I don't even know maybe oranges
[Music]
[Applause]
so what s stealing from us you haven't
come up with anything have you
oh that's where your runs it's got a
bunch of meds in it was in a great on
the outside wall and there's a sign on
the other one
holy [ __ ] yeah okay we line everybody up
everybody
uh-huh somebody's killing us stealing
from that supply is the same as slipping
into your room at night and cutting your
throat while you say thank you
exaggerate the difference what if
Clementine gets sick and we don't have
what we need
it's a good point I'm the help who the
[ __ ] is that what do we do that
escalated quickly again what just keep
them talking do whatever it takes to
stop him pulling a trigger really
confuse right no that's [ __ ] true
stop putting your boot to these doors
but uh then I thought it had a look at
move it [ __ ] take it easy
it was a mixup I'm listening well I
don't know nice going whoa whoa what's
clapping where's climbing
Oh Cal Cal Cal Oh No
what do I do oh I was so close I was bit
about to shoot him let me get in the RV
[Music]
no we gotta save Lily I'm saving Lily I
am fire I am headshot boom headshot well
[ __ ]
boom headshot 316 Poe
okay that wasn't a 360 and wasabi oh ha
I miss goddamn it
where's Lily look last chance get down
here
[Applause]
can't you just run around
did she make it
cat Jesus are you okay I'm fine I'm fine
den I'm sorry everything's fine
everything's NOT fine knowing need to
figure out how this happened we just
locked everything well we're lucky as
[ __ ] to have this RV nobody died cat's
head is split I'm fine
somebody in here cause this settle down
back there
the bandits have had our number for
weeks this is different
what it was was flipping them our meds
they didn't get their last package so
they attacked
calm down back there that's nuts I think
it's getting supplies hidden outside the
wall it's true
so Carly is there something you want to
say I think it's Teddy's we have to get
it out of you then back off you are in
no position to make demands
but neither you're just pointing fingers
paulie's trustworthy it's not a traitor
Lily
Thank You Lee that's right I wanna get
laid battles unless there's something
going on here that implicates you both
no ridiculous like look maybe we should
vote or something like that vote what
just look
Carly's a stand up gal and maybe this
was all just a missile look at the facts
let's calm down we'll eat and we'll deal
with it okay go people make mistakes and
yeah this is a [ __ ] doozy but it's
not worth it living anywhere the Lily
Lily not forget honestly tell me
Kenny can kill my dad Carly could steal
from us where's the line who said Carla
stone all right I'm stealing anything
we'll see you bet you what I've seen you
two together
was it both of you look just let me out
I didn't do it but I don't like this I
don't like where it's headed
look me in the eyes and tell me you
didn't have anything to do with it
reminds me of my teacher off of him I
hit something we gotta stop well we can
deal with this now that
yeah I don't like where this is going
Braz see should be everybody out out
oh she want to do it now doesn't he all
this is not gonna end well for us this
is not gonna end well
hey there's a zombie underneath your
truck man I would not stick my head down
so Clutton i sad holy [ __ ] kami the RV
has some surface damage but there's a
walker trapped underneath
be careful Kenny god damn it
everyone keep your eyes peeled alrighty
then you know what we shouldn't just
kick you out we should hear what
everybody thinks I think you should
chill out I'm not gonna take this you
can push been around but you can't push
me around I'm starting to think maybe it
was both of you
there's no way it was Carly with
somebody else it could have even been
somewhat sneaking into our can get
ridiculous that's what you think
yes okay fine then Kenny I think it was
Kenny I don't know [ __ ] just stop would
you well your vote counts for you and
Concha we don't need all these votes
what do I have to do for you to trust me
I'll do anything
oh I'll do watches for months all right
Lu food medicine and I tell the [ __ ] out
seriously big you need to stop and just
take a breath
do we need any more evidence than fair
[ __ ] evidence stop treating him like
this shut up Riley I've heard enough out
of you Lilly you're acting like a dick
just give me a damn minute
you have until that Walker is dealt with
to tell me it was her and none you stop
this you're torturing him no man stop
this is about trust and I've never
trusted you
just do it well I mean Jesus who are you
right no one so take me out of the
groove we won't understand tell me now
that's not happening you think you're
some tough [ __ ] don't you doesn't hurt
you but you're just a scared little girl
get the [ __ ] over it
Oh try helping somebody for once oh she
does not like that
she did not like that you talk away from
the windows
Jesus Christ get it we're leaving this
crazy place he lives couldn't be trusted
Lee I swear please
are we gonna do with her leave her for
the walkers you're not coming with us
not coming with us I'll die out here I
don't care you're a murderer Lily
we can't have you with us I'm a murderer
you've had Leigh with you this whole
time
I don't care what he did tell me good
you know yeah he told me I don't give a
[ __ ] I keep you with us how long until
you get me I was trying to protect all
of us Lily I'm sorry but straight up
shut Carly for nothing
get in Lee let's go you guys come on
don't make me pity you now you shot it I
can't forgive that I just what but she
shot her I was gonna be made it she's
done you know how much I did to save
Carly and she just straight-up shooter
holy [ __ ]
[Applause]
bonne bonne voie sayonara sayonara Lily
I will never see you again a word please
I want to talk to climb the fence okay
how'd you need you for something I care
more about you Clemmy are you all right
claim I guess I got to talk to the fat
[ __ ]
what's up girl
is stuck feeling alright
oh no oh this is that you can use and
during the raid
whatever they'll have never had a bite
victim in the group before I'm going to
keep an eye on him and see what I can do
from a medical perspective we keep the
same plan unless something changes east
guys what else is there to do we thought
you should know
important to stay honest with each other
anyway if you could tell Clementine we
would appreciate it
god damn so much happening why is
everyone dying honey
honey I'm sorry but your friend is
screwed oh so say darkest did
huh you got bit by a walker - escapable
- I don't feel good what about Carly
God won't come back cuz she was shot in
the head that's right it's horrible
yeah it is
goddamn three characters
I'm glad a heavy flaming me too
I heard you outside my tree house that
day and thought about dropping a hammer
on your head that's nice what why
Oh Kate you were up to no good before
you there was this other guy he was
yelling and trying to get into my house
he wanted to take the TV and tried to
break the glass door with a rock okay
some walkers came and scared him away
door was open he was dumb all righty
then I'm gonna end this episode here
it's it was Ben
yes oh [ __ ]
Oh gonna end this episode here I like it
better if you enjoyed subscribe cover it
today
see you next episode bye I'm a [ __ ]
again lady [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]